So, my name is Lukasz Gandzel and I've
been programming since I was a little
kid and I want to tell you about my
newest project. Um, books reimagined.
So, how to use AI to create new
experiences for things you already know.
So, how it all started?
Uh, I was reading a book about uh,
Donald Trump re-election and since as
you can hear I'm not from the United
States
uh,
if there was a bit a few too many
characters to me. I didn't follow
everyone.
Uh, so I decided to wipe code my way
through the understanding. I uh, built a
little bit of an AI companion
application. Looked terrible, but uh, it
gave me context for the people that were
on the page with a little bit it found
the images for them and gave me a little
bit of a summary in the context of the
of the page that I was at.
And a month later
it turned into
um
it turned into something different. So,
this is going to be the snow this is one
of the first experiences we've built.
This is the Snow Queen book and this is
the part where the sorcerer's uh,
apprentices are flying away with the
mirror that distorts the reality.
Um
So, all right.
So, it tells the story about they're
flying and flying and the heaven is so
far away. There's music and it reads,
but you can't hear it. I'm sorry. But
then the crash happens
and uh
the mirror shatters and it distorts
everything all around. So, this is one
of the first experiences we've built
and uh, but it's all in Polish. So, I
want to actually demonstrate
one that we built just for this
conference that's in English. This is
and
um
what's interesting here, which I don't
think I'll be able to show you, is that
you can send a quick voice note to the
book
and ask what's going on in this scene
right now.
I don't really have audio.
But the the point is that there's many
different uh
AI voice assistants, but they are all
almost always just terrible if not all
of them to be honest. Siri is terrible.
We had a demo from uh, Google yesterday.
They were saying up front that it works
50%
uh,
it's usually there's a delay. They
they start talking in the wrong uh,
position.
Uh, I mean at the wrong time.
Uh, they they interrupt you.
So, we've built here a system where it
you hold it as to just
uh, specify when you are speaking and
you then you let it go and it
immediately 100 milliseconds responds to
you and then you could scroll further
and then ask a question like what
happened between the last time I asked
you a question now and it can summarize
what's going on. Um
So, you have to believe me that you can
check later on bookgenius.net. Um
Another thing that we were talking
thinking about is the search.
That's very
uh, common thing searching.
Uh, so the most normal search would be
just exact search. But if you want to
the way our brains work they don't
memorize the pages. So, if you want to
find a scene where Winston met O'Brien
then exact search is not going to work,
but embeddings work. So, you can quickly
find the scene you were thinking about
this way and then you can uh, go to that
go to that uh, spot, read a bit more and
you can go back to the place where you
were reading.
But there's also uh,
one step forward I mean one more thing
you can do. You can basically say
uh, talk about all the way the party
um, propaganda works and you can do deep
research and it's going to actually read
the whole book till the to the point
that you finished at to give you the
answer.
So, that's very useful. It's going to
take a couple minutes. I'm going to go
back to the presentation.
So
I started with wipe coding vanilla JS
very confusing code, but it gave me the
freedom to iterate very quickly.
Um, you basically don't know what you
don't know and if you start to
especially right now the time it takes
to plan everything up front is often
wasted because you can much quicker just
tell your thinking to the AI and
generate something that works and then
you see oh, that's actually not that
great. Let's try this and that.
And I realized that throwing away code
that you poured your heart into often
feels terrible. Like you're vested,
you've spent so much time. But throwing
away code written by by AI actually
feels great. Um
So
I would describe this as waves of
changes. So, basically
um,
once I start feeling that the I don't
rewrite the whole code base day after
day. Like the the amplitude of the waves
is getting lower and lower and there
comes the time where I can start old
school engineering.
Uh, I can start adding tests and
refactor. But there are traps
refactoring. Do I refactor the worst
piece of code? I would suggest that it's
better to focus on low hanging fruits.
So, for example I had a piece of a code
for from open AI audio processing. Uh,
it's like JavaScript very quickly
written no types very confusing, but I
never have to touch it. So, I'm I'm not
refactoring it. Although it was very
tempting. So, we often think about
refactoring by adding this how bad how
painful how easy. But if something is
very bad and very easy to change, but
it's not painful at all and it's
probably not a good idea to change it.
So, I would suggest that it's better to
look at how bad the code is multiplied
by how painful I multiply by how easy.
When all those factors are taken into
consideration, then it starts making
sense to
make a decision. So
a lot of the AI
experiences that we see and talk about
are basically either chat GPT wrappers
or image generators uh, or half working
useless voice assistants and including
Siri. Um
So our approach was to hide the AI from
the user.
Uh, so when we produce the books the AI
does the initial draft and we do the
rest and I would argue that the human
touch is invaluable in in situations
like this. Uh
Like not AI cannot tell if the music
that they generated is not good. It
cannot say if the graphics are good
looking or if the avatar is actually
matching the vibe of the person
uh, that uh, the book is talking about.
So, you want to make the AI disappear.
And uh, multiple things connected
together simple things simple building
blocks make for the magical experience
for the reader. There's nothing really
new here. You could already ask a friend
about a question about the book. But is
your friend available 24/7 and all
knowing? Probably not. You can already
search, but is the search spoiler free
search? Is it natural language search or
exact match?
Um
So, I think that beautiful graphics help
you get into the mood of the book and
help you with the character recall.
Uh, and music that matches the scene
makes it the experience like watching a
movie and we know that music influences
the emotions hugely and it's very nice
when
um, you're reading the book and the the
music just flows with the book and and
gives you this great experience.
So, nothing new, but at the same time
completely new, which is what AI allows
us to do nowadays and I would encourage
everyone to think about those tiny
little niches where
uh, we can create some completely new
experiences on top of something that we
known for so such a long time. So, in
thousands of years it was never possible
to read books like this nor even really
produce books like this because if I had
to do all those graphics and music per
every single book it would cost me I
don't know 100,000 of dollars per book.
So, it never meant made sense to do
this.
So, how do we do this? The process is we
use a combination of LLMs
to the scene analysis, book characters
detection.
We give the AI an overall music theme.
So, we say for
Sherlock Holmes books for example that
it's like Victorian London and all that
and it should be noir music and kind of
a on a sad note. Um, so with scene scene
analysis plus mood detection we do music
generation and we also do structured XML
with metadata. So, for example we have a
text like this and we
AI is very good at doing this kind of a
mapping which then it's very easy for us
to use in the
uh, book when we say okay like we can
display the avatars that are in the
scene. It would be very time consuming
for a person to go through the whole
book and map every single thing like
this. So, today we are open sourcing the
player. So, anyone can create the
Netflix style experiences for books.
And if you want AI that feels like magic
not like chatbots, come talk to me.
We build AI experiences that ship and
delight and not slides. Although I hope
the slides were nice.
So, thank you and you can find me
at those places.